[Music]
hey you guys and thanks for tuning in to
our last episode of the rosewood rundown
on etv
thanks to you guys thank you thank you
last night
we have a live audience
hi i'm yeah krause i'm leanna aguilera
and joining us today the one the only
marlene king thank you guys so much for
coming in oh my god oh my gosh um so
first of all katie and i of course had i
know i love it thank you to the reveal
but of course we are not actually a.d
spencer had a twin
alex drake oh my gosh
i mean the name the story it's kind of
incredible how you guys kept
that secret truly thank you well detroit
and i had it the longest and trying
literally was you know uh
it was crazy the whole thing was crazy
i'm happy it's over yesterday it was
like a happy sad day yeah yes yeah only
happy it's over in the sense that we
don't have to keep that secret anymore
definitely well for all the fans out
there make sure you guys are leaving
your questions your comments below we
will get to them we are going to ask
marlene everything on our brains on your
brains and i'm really excited to do this
me too i hope i have the answers i hope
you know sometimes we say we have pll
brain and we forget things because it
all turns to mush yeah well there's a
lot it's a lot to remember but from
after today this half of my brain gets
to go back to normal
until your next show and we will be
getting to that as well so you said that
you and troyan have known the salonga so
talk to us marlene at what point did you
decide that troy was gonna have an
identical twin
i think i started thinking about it
between on the hiatus between seasons
five and six because we knew we had two
more seasons to to go and we needed a
new a
and that a had to be the uberist a of
all which immediately makes me think of
spencer hastings because she's so
brilliant and it was a big fan
a lot of fans i think it was a popular
theory that fans wanted one of the plls
to be a d
and because the show is about
unconditional friendship in my opinion
like the at the heart of the show it
really is about friendship and their
unconditional friendship i didn't want
to twist that in the end but but i
thought okay giving spencer a twin
you sort of get to have your cake and
eat it too it's almost like having a
pretty little liar there but not quite
did you ever toy with the idea of making
it one of the girls or having one of
them have a twin well you know yes i
mean
i think for me logically it was spencer
because
from the pilot you know the hastings
lived right next door to the de la renta
says we found out over time that there
was some cross
pollination
family man that family tree
so it's just they were so intermingled
and intertwined that it just felt so
right to bring spencer in into or her
twin yeah give her the twin that she
should be a part of that family talk to
me about that conversation that you had
with troy how did you break this huge
news to her she might correct me but i
think we were at the tower hotel having
dinner sort of celebrating the fact that
we were gonna have two more seasons just
the two of you well ashley and shea were
there but they went outside for a little
bit and i think that's when i told her
like sort of the gist of the story and
then we decided she said please don't
tell the others because i don't want
them to know when it's that that it's
not me in a scene which i thought was
brilliant because it would have affected
their performances so
that's i think that's when i first told
her and then over the course of of a
year we really worked together on on
finding sort of that character because
we knew we had a little time before we
would see a.d on screen yeah but so and
i knew a.d would be british but but troy
and i'm going to call her spencer a lot
troyan
she worked she started working on the
dialect i think a year in advance and
she didn't like randa is like a very
polished brit and and troyen wanted to
be more of like a street sounding you
know like she knew this character
probably grew up on the streets so
i mean it was a lot of detail went into
it can i ask you about the scene that we
flashed back to with troyen and ashley
benson
at that point did ashley know no or she
had no idea she had no idea oh that's so
cool she had no idea and i think little
by little as those we we intentionally
made the scenes that she has electric
like a little something was always a
tiny bit off a tiny bit off hoping the
audience would start to put the clues
together you did maybe you did i'm not
sure
um and and i'd say by the time by
episode 18 where it's alex drake having
sex with toby at the table reads the
cast started started figuring it out or
at least had a theory
are you oh
when okay so there's so many different
times that we've been seeing now alex as
spencer was there a specific time
besides the one with her and toby where
you intentionally left a little crumb
for fans to find because for me it was
the alex and ren scene that we thought
that was spencer that was a little out
of place for me
you know what's really interesting too
is that there was
troyan
directed that episode yeah and and joe
dory wrote it and they really wanted
alex drake to wear a hat right and and
but because
but like spencer's never worn a hat like
this and so there was this big debate
like is that pushing it too far so we
went no hat and i'm so glad because
people still picked up on the fact that
something wasn't right there yeah um but
so yes when originally the first two
times we saw her she's wearing a pink
argyle sweater because she's really
doing spencer right and so but the
second time she has a trench coat on but
she still has the pink argyle sweater on
so there was like one little clue and
i'm trying to think of the other times
we saw her like we saw her
without the bangs okay yeah and so that
was the one little thing that was off in
the hannah dream so there's always
something a little
or she would it was really she was
amazing troy and like she'll notice if
you go back like she fidgets with her
hands when she's a d but not as spencer
see and that's something that i did not
pick up on which i think is so fun now
to hear
um i have to ask you about okay so we
got the whole backstory of alex slash
a.d however we referred to her yes why
was she not as angry with mona who
actually killed
charlotte like why did she not decide to
kidnap her
well i think she she she didn't know
that it was mona until
you know episode 19. right so she
thought it was probably one of the
pretty little liars okay so that's
that's why mona i mean i don't think she
thought mona was the killer i think she
thought it was one of the girls because
they they had reason to pay back
charlotte i guess so did mona as well
okay that makes sense yeah and so and
then just to reiterate for the fans out
there who still might be confused please
tell us if we have this right so
let's see i've got my support system
let me know ages
version of this game was liar's lament
yes that was when she took it over from
she took it over before it was upon
charlotte's death uh-huh okay you you
suffer for season
seven okay six okay
charlotte died and
six six eight yes okay so yes upon
charlotte's death at the end of 6a or
the
end of six eight okay thank you thank
you um you started seeing a black hoodie
and if you go back and you watch those
closers you see a.d be born like you
hear the pats decline music you see a d
opening
like that
connection that we were seeing yeah and
you saw it in the finale like she was
the last time charlotte sees alex she
gives alex this patsy cline album
and which is just heartful soulful music
it happened to be my father's favorite
artist and so that's how it kind of came
into the show but then we all just fell
in love with it i couldn't believe we
could afford patsy cline music because
she's so amazing
but if you go back and you look at the
closers in those first couple episodes
after charlotte died you literally see
the birth of
d being born so then did a d have any
part in the dollhouse
no no nothing to do
if you go back and you just watched the
flashbacks of a.d
in the finale you get a sense of the
timeline like she she didn't want
charlotte to come back here and play the
game they found each other like they
were happy but charlotte couldn't not
play the game
right and then so when charlotte gets
killed then a.d
comes to town to um
avenge her death first of all find out
who killed her and avenge her death yeah
so we have made a list marlene
this is this is the fun part we've made
a list of questions and we're just going
to shoot them off are we going to
apologize in advance because marlene's
about to be put under fire and again
guys if you have questions should you
send them in yes all right here we go
um okay okay here we go why did alex
capture ezra and feel like she and arya
were going to be the closest not
hot air balloon available the next day
yeah and he in that moment figured out
that spencer was not spencer
so that's why she takes him back to
her prison what about her whispering to
arya she kind of like gets into bed with
arya and hannah and she's like i feel
like we're going to be the closest i
think probably because she was like she
knew already that she had you know she
she was going to kill ezra right and i
feel like that's her end with arya it's
like we're going to be the close of all
because i'm about to kill your fiance
so creepy
um okay well speaking of killing um
how did alex kill ren and was he cool
with it
no he wasn't cool with it he wasn't cool
with that and actually this is a fun
little sort of behind the scenes tidbit
originally julian was supposed to be
with us for two days of shooting and
alex was going to kill ren in the finale
because he he didn't want her to just
become
spencer right he said like this is too
much this is too much but then when we
we lost him and only had him for one day
of shooting we had to kill him shooting
the film yeah we had to kill him off off
camera and turn him into the diamond
because
it was a last minute like switcher room
who came up with the diamond idea
because that was so i think it was mine
because i had just seen an ad where you
could turn your pets into gemstones
or
so i don't think he was okay with it i
think it's a he and also in this scene
that was written that we never got to
shot shoot
she literally says to him you know i
love you i love you so much but you're
never going to see me as spencer you're
always going to see me as alex and
that's why she had to kill her this
might be morbid but it's a morbid show
how did she kill him
i think she hits him with a pipe right
and then he fell under like it was going
to be the alley outside of the church on
the morning of the wedding
and the
he goes under the fire escape and and
and she tugs the thing and it comes down
and cuts as one pipe off the ladder yeah
how painful yeah
talk to us but then she said in that
scene she goes you really do have these
babies you really do have your eyes
okay that's my other question is how
come emerson never found out
who the father it didn't occur to me
until people started asking me this
today and i just i in my mind she told
spencer that that alex told spencer that
ren was the father or spencer figure it
out because she knows the connection
between those two okay so i think
off-screen spencer probably told emerson
that ren is the father of your baby so
they do eventually know yes in your in
my mind okay fantastic so and just kind
of adding to that then what did a.d gain
then by making ren the father
beautiful babies for one
right
i mean i think it was just in that scene
the fictional scene that was written
that we never got to shoot like he's
saying you know i've done this for you i
shot you i even gave life for you yeah
right so he knew it he was a part of it
he was a part of that scheme
and i think it was i i think she's just
warped enough to say like here's an
opportunity here's these eggs look what
we can do to these girls will you help
me yeah so twisted yeah twisted sister
so speaking of sisters let's talk about
melissa hastings
was she just the biggest red herring of
the series she yes i think i mean she
did
by accident kill bethany young she
thought bethany was dead and she buried
her alive to protect her sister because
she thought spencer had had killed
allison but it wasn't allison it was
bethany young
um but that's really the only thing she
was guilty of other than being a greedy
older sister [ __ ] yeah yeah
and she was a part of the nat club like
she was on the train the night garrett
died and and is she the one who pushed
arya no i think that was wilden okay
okay that was my other that takes
another one of our questions okay what
was behind the decision then to bring
her back but only in mask
form was that just that was really her
on doing the horse that really is
melissa uh doing the horse but she's
another one we only had her for one day
so it was like okay we really want to
build her into the story yeah we wanted
to keep her as a red herring of course
because she's so great at it
and then
she's such a great actress story like
she'll come back she's been gone for two
seasons she's like tell me what's
happening i'm like how much time do you
have
uh well speaking of the masks that leads
us to the one and only mona
um she was great she was fantastic
for all the emmys out there
um
okay so tell us if this theory is right
okay when someone hauled alex away at
the end was that not a real police
officer that was someone doing mona's
bidding to put her in the stallion exact
person you see later and perry
yeah he's her boyfriend and if you go
back and watch it he even has a twinge
of a french like when he's when he's
arresting alex he's got a twinge of a
french accent it's true yeah but i think
you have to kind of put that together be
like wait that's the police officer so
they didn't really go to jail so that's
how she got them because once again
police did not help at all well nobody
called them because mona called him
right right she was like i'm calling
9-1-1 but really she just called her
boyfriend
hot french boyfriend does this mean even
though mona went back to radley she was
being rehabilitated with halep does that
mean because she has the dollhouse at
the end that she's still a little bit
mental
yes
well cause what what victoria wants to
know is is mona the real mastermind
behind all the torture of the girls no
motor was an original a.d she got lost
in the game charlotte stole the game
from mona and mo and then ad took over
the game for charlotte yeah and then
mona basically just won the game from
alex drake okay
who shot spencer in 710 alex drake okay
so she was hoping spencer would die then
and that's how she knew about spencer's
scar then right and that's when she says
mary saved you right there's a line
where she says mary drake saved you to
spencer in the finale and that's what
she meant like mary saved her on the
night she got shot so when jenna in 7 10
says your id did she then have something
but she didn't know who it was she just
knew like because she can't see right so
but yeah she smelled her last night like
she knew that wasn't spencer so she knew
that that was the same person when she
was like you're a d so she smelled her
it's my favorite oh my god
jenna jenna was another big red herring
i feel like for the entire just the fun
like the opening scene was so fun and so
surreal with like lucas tap dancing bye
i had to get like yeah i've known he can
tap dance for so long i was like before
this show ends i'm gonna have you tap
dancing in this show brenda well and it
was just all a figment of mona's
imagination but so when a.d appeared to
mona and she's like i never would have
guessed it was you
who was showing themselves to her that
was wrong
on the a-team before he was turned into
a gemstone okay because because we were
saying like a whole little bit of a time
jump yeah okay because she was spending
the entire episode trying to get an 80s
good graces to learn who that person was
but then i was like oh did she not know
okay that makes sense so how come
ren never thought to tell spencer or
melissa
about alex
he's like
i think he was in love with alex though
he was enamored by her he was in love
with her and and you know that's
i think that uh that shot to the top of
the list yeah that makes sense with
ally also being alex's cousin
um we were concerned that she wasn't in
the reveal enough
and in on the no what was the decision
to kind of have her be have like a
little step behind
you know i don't i don't know that it
was something that that we consciously
consciously talked about so much that it
was just sort of felt like those things
play so well when they're just very
intimate i i think and so it was the
fewer people down there the better yeah
and there was no reason for a.d to
kidnap allison like she she wanted to
she she needed to kidnap spencer so she
could go be spencer
that makes sense it feels like this
whole game started because of allison
and it started with his whole family and
it kind of switched from the
delaurentises to the hastings to the
drakes to the drake
it's always one big happy family
they all still are very connected yeah
well speaking of big happy families
emerson twins
that is one thing
yes you did you did that was you that
was literally where like it's the final
season yeah go big or go home but if
she's having a baby she might as well
have twins because twins runs in the
family so many babies in last night so
many baby talk can we talk about that
engagement just a little bit and the
dialogue between them because i feel
like alison has been so open in recent
episodes with her feelings for emily
talk about that decision well she she
didn't she was planning this big like
you know let me propose to you in a very
romantic romantic way but emily was
pushing pushing pushing and and she had
no choice but to just be spontaneous in
the moment and and ask for her to marry
her why the pug sweatshirt
i don't know ask cameron
sweatshirt no symbolism just like
because it was just supposed to be not
expected this is not how she wanted to
look and although emily was like shea in
the whole in the whole finale wore
whatever she wanted like she's not
everybody feels she was a little bit
shaved she was that
[Music]
is that the same answer then for arya's
wedding dress being
short arya well her first wedding dress
right was
right and then she she and cameron
worked together and picked both of those
dresses it was very aria yeah yeah and
the second one was just really about
in my mind it was the dress she probably
was going to wear when they were eloping
oh
i love that um
when we discovered that arya couldn't
have kids was such a heartbreaking
moment can you talk a little bit about
the decision to add that extra twist to
that relationship well we really needed
a reason for arya to think that possibly
ezra was going to stand her up at the
altar the next day like you had to buy
yourself a little bit of time there
where she wouldn't immediately jump to
like oh my gosh something must be wrong
something must be wrong yeah and we
thought it was just enough you know of a
story where you know he wasn't mad at
her because you know she couldn't have a
baby but he was upset that she kept it
from him for so long so
can we talk about the barn scene at the
very end because you're right it was a
very full circle moment
and it takes us all the way back to the
pilot episode
is that going to turn in to something
else or was that just kind of for right
now it literally was just like a fun way
to say
one chapter is over but this town
remains this spooky creepy rosewood that
it's going to live on in its own
what happened to eddie lamb wait real
quick before we move to eddie lamb real
quick yeah yeah can we talk about maya's
niece what an amazing twist
how did that come about that was but
actually there's a big fan of the show
her name is crystal crystal salem and
she's friends with that that actress she
really is an actress and she's like you
got to meet my friend she looks just
like my saint germain this was years ago
so for years i've been thinking like how
do i get her on the show how do i get
her on the show and so that kind of was
the starting point of why we started
talking about the new little mini plls
in that full circle moment yeah i love
that okay katie okay i've been waiting
to ask you this
what happened to eddie lamb eddie lamb
left town he's like i gotta get out of
here like he's nice he's not alive he
was a nice person but i feel like he did
favors for people like radley and and he
didn't want to get into trouble so he
just left town ah
my heart feels like lives in like
florida now we're we're retired we're
running out of time so we're going to
try and get as many more same questions
what has been your favorite easter egg
that you put into the entire series or
maybe just the finale
well for the finale i mean i i i love
that that dream seat because we've done
these dream sequences before where the
girls thought they saw alison and we
realized in hindsight most of them it
really was allison so that felt like a
real full circle moment having alex
visit hannah
in that shed in a dream yeah it did
landon wants to know why was null in the
dollhouse what was sarah harvey's a
motive
sarah harvey's a motive
all those people were looking for the
same thing they were looking for alex
drake like sarah harvey thought alex
drake was was going to be
like sarah harvey
a.d says to sarah harvey like she's
looking for her pot of gold she thought
under the radley somewhere there was
money but really it was that file if you
go back and look like right before the
time chopper i forget what it was where
spencer and toby and mona all find that
file which like starts the whole mary
drake thing exactly like she sarah was
looking for money but but she didn't
realize the pot of gold was alex drake
speaking of toby
who killed his mom
that was bethany young
i mean there was like to this day
there's that controversy over that
flashback because that we made the kids
look so much younger yeah um because we
used to play flashbacks like when keegan
was 19 he could play you know a 13 year
old yeah not now that he's a man
so we switched gears on that one which
confused a lot of people but but so yeah
that's the truth okay what about the
maybe they're easter eggs i don't know
but all the twins throughout the series
the blonde twins and then ashley marin
seeing the blonde girl in the marin
house at one point what was that about
that was just a ghost i mean we did cast
the same girl from the twin story that
allison allison told in the first
halloween episode okay but but yeah that
was a legitimate halloween night ghost
showed up at her house
i just thought it was like a hint that
twins were eventually coming
it's all a hint in the sense that you
know sarah played with twins a lot in
the book so whenever we could play along
with that twin idea we just had fun with
it yeah in the same way we had fun with
dolls yeah i loved that all of our girls
got a great happy ending um some fans
were saying that they wish that spencer
and toby's relationship had been a
little bit more established at that very
end how do you imagine their future is
do you think they eventually get married
we did talk about having a double
wedding with ezria and scoby but it felt
so false like that has to be earned i
understand that fans want to see
everything
but it has to be earned and i feel like
they're coming back to each other and if
you were to jump forward a year from the
finale they're together they're probably
engaged they're they're in game well
because he was having to deal with the
fact that he thought he was sleeping
with spencer but it was some other girl
yeah there was that yeah there was that
emotionally impact on the relationship
but i think there was a pretty bow at
the end of that story and the fact that
he was staying in rosewood forest but
also i feel like to me one of the most
romantic things about the whole episode
was him knowing that was spencer as
opposed to alex drake he went straight
yes he knew
a couple more fan questions and then
we'll let you go yes we're awesome
okay andrea says can you please explain
the story behind bethany young well you
kind of already did that yeah
um and then sydney says when mona said i
never would have guessed it was you we
got that one oh we got that one yeah
that was wren do you envision that we
could have a reunion of some kind like
five years down the line ten years down
the line so i think the stars will will
have to align so everybody's you know
available at the same time to sort of
tell and find a great new story to tell
within this world
but it won't be for a while and you know
like i'm excited to do new things the
girls are all excited young ladies are
all excited to go off and do new things
and and i'm excited just to see what
everybody does yeah and you'll keep us
posted on spin-off news right of course
awesome people were very excited when
you mentioned that there could be the
perfectionist
spin-off that it would be in the same
way
that other people have mentioned it and
i just sort of keep saying well maybe
yeah
well maybe works for us right now thank
you so much marlene oh thank you guys
everything thank you guys
of just phenomenal entertainment yes
exactly that's what we set out to do so
it's been so fun and i feel like pretty
little liars really set the precedent of
for social media and tweeting and kind
of bringing a fandom together in the
digital era 1.7 million
by far the most uh
proud of is the fact that worldwide we
brought all these people together you
guys and
that's it that that's our legacy all of
us are still going to be a family even
though the show
ends before we let you go we have a
special surprise for you okay it is uh
the entire cast they have a message
for you actually yes so we have this
excuse that's right so let's go ahead
and take a look okay
oh marlene
i say to the girls you know you'll dance
at my son's bar mitzvah and i will dance
at your weddings mar has been
literally like my second mom
she has so many layers she's so dynamic
marlene is a genius honestly she
is a force marlene is such a
cool chick she just she just really is
she's just the wonder woman she's one of
my closest friends
she's honestly is the mother of my
career and i'll never forget that first
coffee with her and then since then
she's just continued to blow me away her
mind is incredible um
just everything that she creates
just goes incredible places right away
from the first moment that i met her she
just had such a warm
comforting sort of energy to her i would
say that i'm extremely grateful for her
uh believing in me
and for her
keeping this character alive as long as
she had
aside from thank you for these past
seven years of my life and
love that you've given me thanks for the
job thanks for the life thank you for
seeing whatever you saw in me because i
can't believe that
seven years later this is where we are
and i'm a part of this family she's
constructed this amazing show and
we have become a family she's like mama
bear i mean i love her so much i'm so
grateful to her i mean this opportunity
has changed my life so much i i feel so
insanely lucky and it's been so
wonderful to work with her i
look up to her a lot i think
she's the best she's a badass i love her
yeah she's incredible and i'm so excited
to see what she does in the future
come on wow that's amazing you guys i
got some waterproof mascara on
that's so sweet can i get a copy of that
yeah yeah oh girl i'll email it to you
all right it
thank you fans so much for watching
thank you for tuning in all season to
the rosewood rundown we really
appreciate it i'm leanna
katie krauss and of course the brilliant
i love you guys i love you guys
[Applause]
[Music]
you